In 2010, Nokia's factory
near Chennai, India
was among the largest in the world.
Thousands of workers,
most of whom were women,
churned out over 15
million phones per month.
Nokia was a shining example
of the kind of success
that India wanted with manufacturing.
But in 2014,
the plant suddenly had to shutter.
Why?
Because of a tax dispute.
Mobile-phone-making major Nokia shut down
its largest plant at
Tamil Nadu, Sriperumbudur,
making over 8,000 workers jobless.
The dispute was over a
$1.5 billion tax demand,
slapped on retroactively by authorities
for alleged owed taxes.
Essentially this factory
became a ghost town.
Eventually, Nokia and the
Indian government would settle,
but the damage was done.
And there are other examples too:
British companies Vodafone
and Cairn Energy
along with at least 17 other companies
were all involved in disputes.
And while this has been happening,
Prime Minister Narendra Modi
has been trying to attract
foreign investment.
Make in India
has become the biggest plan
that India has ever created.
The bureaucracy can often go against
whatever it is that the political class
is expressly trying to achieve.
While India might be securing jobs
for its highly skilled elite,
complicated, uncertain taxes have pushed
most foreign companies in need
of cheap labor towards China.
That's costing the economy an
estimated $140 billion a year.
They've been saying they're
open to the rest of the world,
but you know, there are
still a lot of protectionist
barriers in doing business with India.
To follow in China's footsteps
and reach the government's goal
of being a $5 trillion economy by 2025,
India needs to create
a model which succeeds
both at home and abroad.
For hundreds of years,
the Indian subcontinent
was among the richest places on earth,
accounting for an estimated
25% of global trade.
Then came the British.
Essentially, Britain kept India
as a supplier of raw materials
for its own factories
and as a market for what
those factories produced.
It's estimated that in today's money
Great Britain extracted
$45 trillion from India.
Fast forward to the late 1940s:
India gained independence
to form a multiparty
democratic system of government.
And across the border,
the Chinese Communist
Party came into power
to form the People's Republic of China.
Suspicious of the west,
and lacking in things they
could sell to the world,
both took a page out of the Soviet Union's
economic playbook, turning
the countries inward.
There was a sense that
they could, of course,
feed themselves and sustain themselves.
China wasn't the only
economy to look inward.
But generally speaking,
the sense of looking
inward was considered to
have been a big contributor
to the depression in the '30s.
In the case of India and China
these centrally planned
economies ultimately didn't work.
But while their economies
largely stood still,
a select few neighboring economies boomed.
They became known as East Asian Tigers.
Hong Kong, Singapore,
Taiwan and South Korea:
They were known as economic wonder childs
from the 1960s onwards.
They boomed in the post-war period.
They had cheap labor,
they had industrial know-how
and they embraced technology.
So all of the toys and
clothes and trinkets
that the western world
was buying in the '60s
and '70s and 80s, all of that was made
in these tiger economies.
It was an economic model that
was an envy of the world.
But there's no doubt when
it comes to the ultimate
model for China, they
have looked to Singapore.
Chinese officials flooded into Singapore
routinely to visit, for study
and to learn from Singaporean know-how.
Obviously the scale doesn't compare,
but what China saw in
Singapore, they liked.
There was that degree of authoritarianism.
There was that degree of anti-corruption.
There was of course
that sense of efficiency
and productivity and its
industrial- and export-led model.
China liked it, and they
looked to Singapore,
and they embraced a lot of it.
In 1978, Deng Xiaoping announced
the Open Door Policy,
to allow foreign companies
to set up in China.
Their biggest asset:
a seemingly limitless
low-skilled workforce
that could fill large
factories with laborers.
They had huge workforces,
huge industrial facilities,
and they were hungry for foreign capital,
foreign know-how and foreign investment.
And when all of those
ingredients were mixed together,
what you saw was a great
shift of global manufacturing
into China, especially of low-end goods,
toys, plastic, linens, trinkets,
all of that shifted to China.
And we saw an explosive manufacturing boom
in the '80s and in the '90s especially.
China averaged 10% growth per year
in the year since it opened in 1978.
Almost 800 million people
have been pulled out of poverty in China
since the great reopening.
Starting in the mid-'80s
and then in a big way after 1991,
India also opened its doors.
Although not normally thought
of as an exporting powerhouse,
India's export growth has been
the third best in the world,
behind China and Vietnam.
That has been a big puzzle
because yes, India is an
exporting success story,
but what is it that India
actually makes and exports?
Instead of low-end manufacturing
such as trinkets and
textiles made by China
and other East Asian Tigers,
the country has uniquely focused
on high-skilled
manufacturing and services,
such as software,
business-process outsourcing
and engineering goods.
This has created a bias
in jobs and opportunities
for a relatively small, English-speaking,
well-educated minority.
But those previously left behind
are getting another shot
thanks to technology.
To give you an example,
a seller who used to have a
brand or used to have a product,
which was limited to one district
or one city had no idea how
to expand the distribution
and reach to 4,000 miles
away from their home city.
But because of the
digitization of economy,
a seller can now dream big,
they can think about becoming
an Indian large entrepreneur
versus becoming a entrepreneur
only for that particular city.
With the help of apps like Udaan,
Indian entrepreneurs are getting access
to tens of millions of retailers
catering to 1.3 billion consumers.
And the mom-and-pop shops
selling these products,
known as kirana stores, can
make better purchases faster,
and receive credit they would otherwise
struggle to get.
Before the platform existed,
they will rely on multiple sources.
They will rely on local distributors.
They have to do multiple
price negotiations
because every time they
have to do multiple deals.
They will have to find multiple
lenders to provide them.
Then they will need to
coordinate the transportation
to get the goods,
or to make sure that they are available
in their store to receive the goods.
Access to smartphones and cheap data
is transforming industries
that have been stagnant for a long time.
It's enticing new entrepreneurs
to produce and sell products
with money pouring in
from investors in Silicon Valley
hoping for a piece of the industry.
Local manufacturing boost will really help
because you will see a
lot more Indian brands
dominating the shelves
in India and overseas.
And this whole digital economy
and internet is providing that platform
to give that access to information,
access to product, access to capital,
access to credit, and that's
really helping our economy.
Another economic boost
is coming in the form
of generous government subsidies
to makers of everything from
electric cars to textiles.
And as these industries grow,
India can tap into its
most obvious advantage:
its booming population,
set to surpass China over the next decade.
Now, the tide has turned
and the Chinese population from here on is
only going to become older.
The median population age in India
is still below 30,
and India still probably
has around three decades
before its population
too is considered old.
Now that's three decades,
a wonderful opportunity.
If India plays its cards right,
500 million people will
enter the middle-income class
over the next decade.
This will be the largest growth
into the middle class
anywhere in the world,
fueling massive domestic demand.
As the middle class grows,
the purchasing power will come.
So India definitely has a
story to tell the world,
that it is ready to fill the gap
that is going to be left behind by China
as two things happen.
One, as China wants
to move out of low-value-added,
low-skilled markets,
and as the economic estrangement
between Beijing and Washington grows,
India has a role to fill.
But choosing India over countries like
Vietnam still has many disadvantages.
Although almost every industry
is now open to foreign investment,
import tariffs have been
increasing since 2018.
And the import process remains convoluted
and time consuming,
a drag on today's interconnected
global supply chains.
The problem is at the level of customs
and the level of disputes
with the customs authorities
on whether something is chargeable.
So the Indian government is involved
in just too many tax disputes
with its private sector.
Income-tax disputes, import-duty disputes,
GST disputes now.
Modi's Make in India
campaign is threatening
a return to the failed socialist
model of self-reliance,
something that might only benefit
a select group of
politically connected firms.
In India, politicians do have to go
and win elections every five years.
And these are very expensive elections,
and they have to be fought
with corporate donations.
So, which means that in India,
the political class
has to strike a balance
in terms of how it deals
with the private sector.
But high tariffs and other trade barriers
might restrict Make in India
to just Make for India,
when the much larger opportunity
is in making things for the world.
It's simply not possible
to become an exporting powerhouse
just by yourself without
importing anything from anybody.
Just to give you an example,
India is a big exporter of human hair.
India's tradition of
sacrificing hair at temples
and the practice of saving
and collecting hair from
individual households
means that it's become the world's largest
supplier of human hair.
The majority gets exported
for manufacturing into wigs,
mannequins and also
other extension products
and made into products suitable
for different markets across the world.
But before exporting hair,
companies may need to add
imported products to it
in order to boost value
and grow their business
or make it suitable for
international clients.
The barrier comes or the challenge comes
when you want to do value-added products,
and the value-added
products you need to import,
for example, keratin glue,
a type of protein glue which
is made in Italy or China,
which clients prefer.
Now, there is another product,
which is imported lace.
Now all of these importation,
the process becomes a challenge
for the smaller ones to grow bigger.
Confusing taxes and high import tariffs
meant to protect the local
market from foreign competition
are major hurdles companies face
when trying to access overseas markets.
It might be sounding crazy to you
that it should be straightforward.
A chemical used in a company in China
should be able to be imported.
But apart from these
importation challenges,
the import taxes are generally kept high
because they want to use
the local source.
But being the hair industry,
and it is not an industry which
is well-developed in India,
so for us,
import is a big
requirement.
Whereas the Indian government
does not understand
that the importation,
if they bring it down,
will be a long way in terms of making more
further value-added products.
Although larger companies
like Raj Hair International
have worked with the
government for decades
to grow their business,
many smaller companies
in India aren't so lucky.
It's kept expansion
and those crucial salary
jobs at a minimum.
I think the statistic is 87%.
That is the workforce that
is either in agriculture
or is self-employed
or is casual labor.
And only about 10%
are getting a salary from someone.
Beyond that 10% of workers
earning a steady salary,
most live day to day with little to show
by way of social security
or medical insurance.
You have a country that is
teeming with surplus labor,
a situation that has been
made infinitely worse
by the coronavirus pandemic.
And yet India is not able to demonstrate
to the global community
that it is actually serious
about inviting and then
retaining the capital.
Another major missed opportunity in India:
its unemployed female population.
Its female participation rate
is among the lowest in the world.
You today have a situation
where Bangladesh's
women
in workforce participation rate
is 40%, and India's is 20%.
Probably India has gone down
even further after the
coronavirus pandemic
because a lot of women
workers, more so than men,
lost their jobs.
But clearly you can't
be making
progress at the level at
which India wants to progress
if only one-fifth
of half of your population
is going to be employed in the workforce.
Bangladesh, which started out
as a much poorer country
and established independence
with the help of India,
has recently passed
India in GDP per capita.
Bangladesh is playing to its strengths.
It is not doing high-tech manufacturing.
It is essentially doing low-skilled work,
work which is going to absorb its labor.
There are signs this
would also work in India.
In the state of Tamil Nadu,
where the Nokia factory once ran,
a number of manufacturing facilities
have been built in the last decade.
Now the state has the second-highest GDP
and one of the highest female
participation rates in India.
So clearly there is a kind
of advantage for women
to get into new factories and jobs.
As late as probably last month,
the Ola company has
started electric scooters
and the entire manufacturing
for the first time
is done by women.
Only women workers have been mobilized.
And this entire factory
and manufacturing is done
by women with the help of robo.
It has also broken the myth
that in the manufacturing sector
or in the automobile sector,
you require male help.
Although gender and caste inequalities
still exist in India due
to differing education
and treatment from a young age,
regular, secure work may
offer a way out of the cycle.
Now if you take IT sector
employment, almost 80%
are all from the so-called forward caste.
However, welcoming factories into India
means there will be infusion
of informal sector workforce,
particularly women into
manufacturing sector,
which is happening and which
is going to bring about
what has been already
conceived from 1990s.
It will be a new growth model as well.
While the Indian government declined
to comment on record,
they have taken steps to try
and make doing business easier.
The goods and services tax or GST
consolidated several state and
federal taxes into just one.
And they've stopped allowing
retroactive taxation.
But the country will
need to go even further
if it's to challenge
its biggest competitor.
Well, India is this economy
that's always considered
to be the next China,
but every time this conversation comes up,
it's still the next China.
One reason, by the way,
economists say what China
did may not work for India.
That's called automation.
China took advantage of cheap manual labor
and making goods for
the rest of the world.
Now we're moving into a
world of rapid automation.
So India can throw open its doors
and offer cheap factories
to the rest of the world.
But in fact, a lot of companies
and multinational companies are saying,
we're embracing robots,
we're embracing automation.
The model that worked for China
may not necessarily be
a carbon copy for India.
When you say China, it
is got a positive vibe
when it comes to manufacturing
and a negative vibe in a geopolitical way.
So India doesn't want to be
the next China, I think so.
India will be India.
At the same time, we will be up-skilled
and developed in our own processes,
but India definitely
will stand by the world
to be the next big
manufacturing hub to source
and get products developed
for the world market.
The focus has to be on
making the society work for everyone
and to give everyone a stake.
Now that is something that
East Asia did very well
because somehow they managed to
get a buy-in from the public
at large for their policies,
by showing them the
way to a better future,
if not for them, then for their children.